[Music]
so it's gonna sound weird by have a
slightly complicated relationship with
Zootopia when the film first came out I
thought was okay and had some criticism
that I thought it was a little too
obvious it was clear what it was trying
to say the way it was trying to say it
and at the time I didn't think it needed
to be made so clear I can't account for
when this video is being watched but I
can say at the current moment I'm
recording this being clear about this
subject especially to a younger
generation is probably more important
now than it has been in a while the
story focuses around judy hopps the
first bunny to officially be a police
officer as such though a lot of the
other bigger animals don't really give
her much attention and kind of just put
her aside when she stumbles across a
case though as some kind of device
that's turning animals Savage that is
turning predators into literal blood
hungry animals she's put on the case
along with a con artist named Nick who
seems to have a lot of information and
understanding about it as typical buddy
cop movies go though they don't always
get along see their differences can be
really big differences but see their
similarities can also be very big
similarities they get in fights blow up
have misunderstandings but in the end
comprehend what's most important as well
as of course uncovering the evil scheme
and putting the evil villain away so
like I said this sounds like a very
standard buddy cop movie just done with
animals but it turns out this is more
like in the heat of the night than it is
lethal weapon
the idea is somebody is trying to turn
all the animals against each other
particularly against the Predators the
Predators despite being as civilized as
anyone else are being made to look like
dumb evil blood hungry monsters in an
especially important scene Judy who was
very likeable brings up that she
actually has a little bit of a prejudice
against predators that she never even
considered
it's a prejudice she was unaware of and
doesn't want to believe she ever had all
right so it's already kind of a risky
move for a Disney anime movie to talk
about race and race Wars and so forth
but to have the incredibly likeable main
character have a little bit of a
prejudice herself is a ballsy move the
idea of the film is not to say one side
is to blame it's quite the opposite
everybody has the capacity to be
something they shouldn't
want to be helped miles don't want to be
yet in some way or another
still sneaks its way through using the
metaphor with animals while obvious is
still pretty clever we see them grow up
with the image that's projected onto
them and we understand it because we
project images onto animals bunnies are
cute
foxes are sneaky wolves are dangerous
but the more the movie invites us into
these different environments and these
different people in these different
cultures the more we understand their
world but still from a child's point of
view you can see officer Hopps running
through this tiny little neighborhood
that's really creative and really funny
but you can also see why that
neighborhood exists what kind of
characters hang out there and why they
hang out there it's something that can
very easily be connected to reality
because of this the film doesn't come
across quite as preachy as you would
think it isn't as simple as racism and
Prejudice is just bad it does analyze
why it exists where it can be found and
how so many can exploit it to their own
game like I said when I first saw it I
enjoyed it I just thought it was
hammering the nail on the head a little
too hard but with the amount of current
crimes that seem to not understand the
message of this film it makes me realize
now it needs to hit it on the head and
it needs to do so in a way that both
kids and adults can get I've know people
from every political background who
enjoy this film
Democrat Republican conservative liberal
it doesn't matter it still connect as a
smart funny family picture and it seems
like the majority of people that see it
get the idea and agree with it on top of
that though it is a really creative
movie I mean just the layout of the city
and the different parts and how they're
all designed to somehow welcome every
type of animal it leads to some funny
jokes but also some clever analogies I
also like the designs of these animals
too like this Nick character even if you
never told me who voiced him I would say
that's Jason Bateman I don't know how
they do it but just look at him you can
tell that's Jason Bateman voicing that
character even if he never talks the
expressions the movements the colors it
all works so like they say timing is
everything
I never disliked this film I never
realized the actual
Oren's of it like a lot of great stories
it can speak to children on one level
and then speak to adults in a different
level but not just through kids jokes
and adult jokes it does so through
dramatic kids themes and dramatic adult
themes making this movie about animals
surprisingly very human so yeah when I
first saw it I thought it could have
been even funnier or play around with
convention a little bit more but
strangely enough you have to see
something very familiar in order to
invoke change and there's nothing more
familiar than a mirror and this movie
did a good job mirroring the comedy we
want to see the characters we want to
see and the changes we want to see
here's hoping even obvious can be
obvious enough
[Music]
you